hi this is dr gregory sadler
i'm a professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years
and i find that many people run into
difficulties reading classic
philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on one core concept
from an important philosophical text
i hope you find it useful as well
in chapter 7 of his book the most
good you can do peter singer
is considering the possible motivations
for
effective altruists and effective
altruism
and you could say well why does this
matter isn't it enough just to do the
the right thing to get with the program
singer thinks that
you know like most ethicists unless you
have the right motivation
it's not that the act itself is going to
be
bad he is a consequentialist right but
you're not going to consistently do the
right thing
or the the good thing or the better
thing as an effective altruist so
if if a person wants to figure out how
to motivate themselves
let's say they get into the movement
they're like oh i buy into this
how are they going to keep doing it
after a month
after a year as a choice of
life path or lifestyle which is what
effective altruism
really is it's a philosophy of life
so the question is well what would
provide the motivation
for effective altruism
not just a single effective altruistic
acts but as a kind of program so
he considers the possibility of
conformity to social norms and you know
you could imagine a community in which
people are brought up
as effective altruists sort of along the
lines of you know
john stuart mill talking in
utilitarianism about this possibility of
getting you know many people to buy into
it and then it would become
part of the culture well that's not part
of the culture now
so being an effective altruist actually
means
being counter-cultural in a number of
important ways so
merely conformity to social norms is not
going to in most cases get you
effective altruism and he doesn't
consider any you know big hypothetical
examples there
a stronger contender would be what he
calls there
universal love and he doesn't dwell on
this because this is more of a popular
book but he could you know have in mind
something like
in chinese philosophy we have moism
named after moza
right which preached a universal
benevolence to all we can see
that there are you know similarities to
that in
western philosophy um you know sort of a
universal benevolence towards all people
was was preached by
among others the stoics um there's
there's a number of
of you know people and movements across
history
that have talked about this and you
could think about you know christianity
and um you know this universal agape
that's displayed
more in what you do than in what you
feel couldn't that be a
sufficient motivation so singer
says that you know sometimes we hear all
we need is love
or we declare our fellow humans our
brothers and sisters could that work
and he brings up david hume who he talks
about several times in this chapter and
he says
uh hume says there's no such passion in
human minds as the love of mankind
merely as such independent of personal
qualities
or of services or of relation to oneself
and then he talks about darwin
talking about um you know giving a a
scientific underpinning to hume's
observation
and and he brings up you know frauds to
wall as well
singer thinks that you can by looking at
human beings and our biological
and evolutionary makeup and he talks
about this in other places you can get
something
like love coming out of that as you know
normal i mean obviously some people
because of their their trauma
or things going on in their brain don't
don't feel
any attachment to anybody but this
doesn't get you
anything remotely close to universal and
it
is a great quote here from uh
here we go elliot sober and david sloane
wilson
group selection favors within group
niceness
and between group nastiness so
universal love is not going to cut it
not as a motivation according to singer
it could be a program you could say that
universal love is something that is
being enacted by both utilitarianism and
effective altruism but it can't be the
motivation for it
well what about something else what
about empathy this is a
word that's thrown around a lot by
people today he brings up the example of
barack obama
writing to a young girl and saying we
don't have enough empathy i suggest you
look it up
and so you know well what about empathy
could this be the basis
for um you know for
some sort of altruistic ethics that
would you know
think about things and tabulate and
correlate and pick the best solution
like utilitarianism
or effective altruism do and
you know i put all these other terms up
here because i do want to signal the
fact that this is not a radically
new idea the term has changed right
empathy is something
it's a very 20th and 21st century word
in the past david hume for example
talks about sympathy as do so many other
people
in the 17th and 18th century not well
into the 19th century
as well right compassion is another term
that we see that's covering a lot of
similar ground
and somebody might quibble and say oh no
no i distinguish empathy from compassion
well you only do that from a theoretical
perspective that
not everybody agrees with the ordinary
person on the street
and is not reflected in the history of
of ideas
um even going further back into like
ancient
you know ancient and medieval ideas we
could talk about pity
or mercy misericordia can be translated
as either of those eleos from which we
get the
you know seminary professions like
nursing and doctoring and being an emt
comes from the greek word for pity and
whenever we see that we often think oh
you're
you know you're looking down on somebody
and pitying them no it's very similar to
what uh we nowadays call empathy
so there's a long history of thinking
that
that empathy broadly construed would
play a role
in moral reasoning and in guiding
our actions but we have to ask well okay
what is empathy then
it's a nice buzzword it sounds really
good
you know if it's a good thing maybe it
would be even better if we had more and
more of it
and singer says well hold on there we
need to distinguish between
emotional aspects of empathy and
cognitive aspects of empathy um there
you know they can
work hand in hand they often do but
they're not exactly the same thing
and so we need to make some fine
distinctions here he brings up the
interpersonal reactivity inventory that
mentions four distinct components is
this the only way to parse out empathy
no but it's
it's pretty good empathetic concern
is one of them the tendency to
experience feelings of warmth compassion
and concern
for other people that's what a lot of
people have in mind
when they're talking about empathy right
the tendency to experience feelings of
warmth compassion concern with other
people
obviously this overlaps with care
with attachment with all sorts of
other affective emotional
matters within that register doesn't it
personal distress this is the second one
one's own feelings of personal unease
and discomfort in reaction to the
emotions of others now
this does not mean feeling bad because
somebody else is feeling
happy they probably should be more clear
that it's about feeling distress
or you know some sort of upset in
relation to
distressful or negative or troublesome
feelings on the part of other people so
you see somebody else
getting hurt you feel bad because you
can tell
that they're hurt that is what he's
talking about there
right um could be with anger could be
with jealousy could be with fear
could be all sorts of things along these
lines so those are aspects
of emotional empathy right
those are what a lot of people mean when
they say empathy but
there are some important cognitive
aspects as well
and i'm going to talk about what they
call the fourth one third
just to sort of get it off the plate
fantasy
is the tendency to imagine oneself
experiencing the feelings and performing
the actions
of fictitious characters so this part
would be you know what goes on when we
watch a movie and we
identify with a character i always get
kind of you know because my
own personal history i see somebody
making a difficult
sacrifice uh against their own
interest for the good of another person
sometimes that can make me
feel a little uh affected you could say
or you know when i see
funeral scenes or something like that
sometimes i i get affected and i can
it's partly imagining myself there with
the characters who don't even exist
right
and this can happen with space shows or
you know songs or pick whatever you want
you know there's a song by the metal
group tank
about a family who loses a child who
falls through the ice
and is never going to grow up you know
well every time i hear that i get a
little bit teary-eyed
that's that's an example of fantasy now
that's partly cognitive because we're
using our imagination it is also
partly emotional here's where we get to
the the really important part
perspective taking perspective taking
the tendency to adopt the point of view
of other people and this is where we
see what we're calling empathy in some
respect overlapping with
you know what daniel goleman is called
emotional intelligence
we see this in all sorts of uh
you know ethical theories going way back
into antiquity
and all the way into the 20th and 21st
century so this is a really important
part
it's not simply feeling what somebody
else is
is feeling or feeling in reaction to
what they're feeling
it's not simply feeling attachment to
them it's not simply
emotional contagion or anything like
that it's actually being able to say oh
man i can tell
that person is hurting i'm not actually
hurting
but i i can't actually understand
that they are and that matters right
even though i'm not myself
feeling it that's cognitive so then we
can ask
okay for effective altruism is empathy
what we want
is that going to get us the sort of
actions
that effective altruism thinks are
important and the the you know long and
short of it is
emotional empathy is not only not needed
but sometimes is actually going to
interfere with effective altruism and
singer brings up examples that i think
many of us
already know about where
we we can focus on one single person
and feel empathy towards them but if we
think about their village
we don't we're not moved in a similar
way or if we think about
one needy child and then we think about
100 needy children
we're less moved in relation to the
emotionally moved in relation to the
hundred needy children
even though there's you know 100 there's
99 more of them there's a hundred times
the one child we we should be 100 times
as moved we're not
that doesn't work that way he also
brings up the trolley problem which is
you know quite interesting
but we can put aside for the moment so
sometimes emotional empathy is not going
to lead to effective altruistic behavior
well why not so you know singer tells us
that effective altruism is not exactly
the same thing as utilitarianism but
it's
it's covering a lot of the same ground
right and we
value each person as a person
from a sort of higher perspective of who
is being helped who is being
harmed can we produce more good
can we prevent more bad can we you know
alleviate
suffering all those sorts of things and
so
he tells us that effective altruism
is really going to be relying upon
reason like he says in particular they
they agree with utilitarians that other
things being equal we ought to do the
most good we can
this is when he brings up the trolley
problem the trolley problem if you're
not familiar with it i mean it's been
done
ad nauseum runaway trolley going down
the tracks
you can flip a switch if you flip the
switch it doesn't kill the five people
that it's hurtling towards but does kill
one person
there's a variant of pushing a fat man
off onto the tracks from a bridge
it all boils down to the same thing are
you willing
to shift things around in such a way
as to reduce the amount of harm or
produce the greater amount of good
so effective altruism
and utilitarianism are going to be using
reason to
decide this and then it becomes what we
typically call a no-brainer right
obviously you flip the switch and you
save the five people even though
one person is going to die
empathy may not get you there empathy
might actually have you so fixated on
the plight of the one person
or the fat man that you're about to push
off the bridge
that you allow the other five to be
crushed by the trolley wheels and so you
know he goes out and he says
in response to those who think that what
the world need most needs is an
expansion of empathy
bloom writes our best hope for the
future is not to get people to think of
all humanity as family that's impossible
it lies instead in an appreciation of
the fact
that even if we don't empathize with
distant strangers
their lives have the same value as the
lives of those we
love now that is really really important
here
what's going to get you that valuation
of the lives of people that you don't
know and don't care about
in an emotional sense being as valuable
as those
of your family or friends or co-workers
or whoever else it is or
yourself it's going to be reason the
faculty of reason
here he brings up hume again and he says
you know hume tells us that reason can
never initiate an action because all
action starts with a passion or desire
hume wrote reason isn't ought to be only
the slave of the passions
now that is actually i should point out
a misreading
a truncated reading of hume and it's
hume being quite rhetorical and then
being misunderstood by generations of
people
afterwards who don't actually read the
portion of the treaties that this comes
from
because if they did they would realize
that huma actually talks about
how you know reason actually does
motivate action
in that very section in relation to
calm passions or things like that so
it's it's
you know it's a bit of a mis
understanding
and instead of trying to break that down
um
singer just brings up kant and then he
talks about henry cedric
and henry cedric he says the last of the
great 19th century utilitarians
shared with kant the belief that ethics
has a rational basis but he did
more than kant to make this a credible
form of motivation
he held that there are self-evident
moral principles or axioms which we
grasp
through our reasoning capacity not just
through
feeling our way into them and so you
know here's here's a
the most relevant one the good of any
one individual is of no more importance
from the point of view if i may say so
of the universe
than the good of any other unless there
that is their special grounds for
believing the more good is likely to be
realized in the one case
than the other eventually he gets to
this uh
he says here's another principle it's
evident to me is that as a rational
being
i'm bound to aim at good generally
insofar as it's attainable by my efforts
not merely a particular part of it right
and this particularity is a great thing
to bring up because when it comes to
you know benevolence doing good to
others
the utilitarians already signaled this
way back in the time of jeremy bentham
as the problem of particular versus
general or
universal benevolence right and uh
you know this this whole idea about
tying in with your own social group well
that's particular benevolence that's
particularity and that's that's a
problem from utilitarian point of view
siddwick coming back to him deduces this
this maxim
of benevolence each person is morally
bound to regard the good of any other
individual as much as his own except in
so far as he judges it to be less
when impartially viewed or less
certainly knowable or attainable
by him and singer says okay this is a
pretty good basis
for effective altruism this expression
of you know utilitarianism
reason would be what would be motivating
us doesn't mean that we rule out
empathy all together if that wants to be
a support for reason that's that's a
okay
if it interferes with reason now we have
a problem
because the whole goal is to ultimately
get to effective altruism as
a consistent disposition decision making
procedure
and way of life
you